boa noite boa noite boa
noite já tem algumas pessoas dando boa
noite aqui
Isabel Josiane Fran Sérgio Nei Gabriel
Jéssica Silmara Viviane Darlene Carmen
Michele
Alexandre Paulo Reinaldo Valdi quanta
gente
É isso aí Valdi Manda um oi aí pessoal
Manda um oi para ver quem é que tá
conectado Quem é que tá online aqui
conosco aproveitem fale da onde vocês
são Qual a especialidade de vocês porque
assim a gente consegue direcionar melhor
esse
congresso cmara O som tá funcionando
aqui tá funcionando para todos vocês
avisa aqui se o som tá
normal a Silmara disse que tá sem
som Belo
Horizonte Curitiba endócrino Alex boa
noite boa noite me avisa se tá sem som
ou com som aqui pessoal por
favor som Está ok aqui
massa Minas Gerais é Minas Gerais tá
ganhando hein Minas Gerais tá ganhando
vamos lá deixa eu preparar aqui a
apresentação para
vocês vamos lá pessoal quem estiver
chegando Não se preocupem tá vai
mandando boa noite para eu saber que
você está online para eu saber que você
tá prestando atenção me fala da onde
você é e qual a sua especialidade tá
porque essa apresentação aqui você não
vai ver em nenhum outro lugar aqui
dentro vou mostrar a inteligência
artificial que envia pacientes
particulares para você com data e hora
marcada Então vou te mostrar Por que a
gente envia e como é que a gente envia
com data e hora marcada tá bom sejam
bem-vindos vão chegando
eh peguem um papel pegu uma caneta tá
porque o que eu vou falar para vocês é
importante
é a gente vai est falando muito sobre
inteligência artificial e como outras
pessoas em vários outros cenários e
principalmente dentro da Medicina está o
usando também então isso vai ser muito
importante para vocês implementarem
dentro do negócio da clínica do
consultório de vocês tá o que eu vou
mostrar aqui hoje vai fazer com que você
nunca mais precise depender de planos de
saúde a não ser que você queira tá você
não precisa criar conteúdo na
internet você não precisa gastar o seu
dinheiro com agências de marketing
generalizada que eu sei que é o caso da
maioria das pessoas aqui tá e você não
precisa ter seguidores para ter
resultado Tá bom então se vocês quiserem
me ajudar também coloca aqui embaixo
Quem já tem agência hoje trabalhando e
se tá satisfeito ou não Tá
bom então tudo que vocês vão aprender
aqui hoje o porque eu decidi explicar
esse método para vocês a forma que hoje
as pessoas utilizam para captar
pacientes Como funciona o nosso método
que é o método máquina de agendamentos
automáticos E como você vai ter
pacientes particulares todos os dias tá
como eu sei que a maioria de vocês gosta
de se organizar assim como eu eu já
deixo aqui o tempo máximo de duração
desse congresso que é em torno de 1 hora
tá bom para vocês se programarem ficar
calmos que em uma hora a gente finaliza
Tá bom então vamos
lá quem sou eu né quem é essa pessoa que
vai falar sobre inteligência artificial
para vocês meu nome é Estela tá eu sou
médica também uma das as minhas maiores
especialidades é captação dentro do
nicho médico então eu sou uma das
maiores especialistas hoje em captação
de pacientes para médicos tá Muita gente
me pergunta hoje eu não atuo mais dentro
da Medicina aturei durante alguns anos
mas hoje eu sou focada nessa parte de
marketing inteligência artificial para
otimizar e acelerar os negócios dos
médicos tá Eu já estive nos bastidores
de grandes players do mercado digital tá
bom dentro da área de saúde fora da área
de saúde também e eu sou fundadora da
vero Tá bom já foram alguns múltiplos
sete dígitos faturados dentro da
internet e por qual motivo a minha
equipe ela é tão procurada pelos médicos
hoje é simples Antes de eu me tornar
médica eu já era uma das referências do
mercado digital Tá eu já fazia alguns
lançamentos já lançava alguns produtos
dentro de vários outros nichos Então já
trabalhei no nicho de saúde Já trabalhei
no nicho eh de nutricionista Finanças
milhas medicina e através desses
lançamentos a minha equipe foi se
tornando cada vez mais conhecida o outro
motivo é porque hoje eu sou uma das
únicas médicas que ensina sobre como
captar pacientes para médicos porque o
que a gente tem muito hoje são
profissionais não médicos tentando
ensinar para vocês o que é ter uma
clínica O que é captar pacientes né
Então temos poucas pessoas hoje com a
real
vivência e isso fez né a vivência na
medicina e a vivência no Marketing fez
com que eu tivesse uma experiência que é
difícil a gente encontrar hoje no
mercado Então hoje nós temos aqui dentro
a base teórica né dos conhecimentos de
marketing como atrair os pacientes como
chamar atenção das pessoas utilizando as
estratégias de marketing conceitos sobre
o mercado de atuação né isso a maioria
das pessoas vão ter Tá bom mas também a
gente tem aqui dentro a base prática que
é vivenciar na pele medicina entender de
fato que um paciente eh precisa né
entender de fato que faz um paciente
escolher um médico em relação ao outro e
saber o que que funciona para médico e o
que que não funciona que é o que a gente
chama aqui de conhecer as regras Tá e é
por isso que hoje o nosso método ele é
muito efetivo dentro da Medicina tá
então da pergunta que eu fiz que que a
galera falou ó sem agência sem agência
tem uma agência mas só para
impulsionar tá bom beleza Vamos lá eh eh
essa esse congresso aqui é importante a
a participação de vocês também tá bom E
foi com essa experiência que a gente
criou o método inédito que traz que leva
pacientes particulares para vocês todos
os dias com data e hora marcada e até o
final dessa apresentação é uma promessa
minha eu vou te mostrar como de fato o
nosso método funciona e eu vou mostrar
isso na prática Tá
certo então vamos lá primeira coisa
Bahia massa por qual motivo eu criei o
primeiro método da Medicina que leva
pacientes prontos com data e hora
marcada pessoal sempre que a gente né
Sempre que a gente vai criar algo a
gente precisa fazer uma pesquisa antes
tá então antes de criar qualquer produto
antes de criar qualquer estratégia antes
de criar qualquer oferta nós fazemos
pesquisa antes para entender o nosso
público e foi o que eu fiz eu fiz uma
pesquisa com centenas de médicos tá
alguns colegas meus tá e eu percebi que
77% estavam tendo prejuízo com a
prospecção digital
O que é prospecção digital prospecção é
ir atrás né captar pessoas dentro do
digital ou essas pessoas estavam tendo
prejuízo ou elas não estavam tendo
resultado desejado ou seja contratavam
agências que elas solicitavam para
captação de pacientes e ol elas tinham
um prejuízo com o que elas investiam
elas não tinham resultado desejado tá
Inclusive eu quero perguntar para vocês
hoje vocês estão satisfeito satisfeitos
com a captação atual de vocês ou seja
vocês estão satisfeitos com a atração de
pacientes que vocês têm hoje ou vocês
querem melhorar o número de pessoas que
chegam até vocês responde aqui para mim
enquanto vou beber uma
aguinha responde aí pessoal
vamos
interagir Nei falou Estou ansioso para
saber dessa
mágica aí vamos lá então quero melhorar
Quero melhorar Quero melhorar tenho
agência mas não Tô satisfeita tenho que
melhorar a qualidade dos meus leads a
gente vai falar sobre isso aqui também
melhorar Tô satisfeita mas pode melhorar
aqu tá maioria quer melhorar vamos
lá Quero melhorar o número de Não
entendi melhorar tá a maioria quer
melhorar então foi isso que eu encontrei
na minha pesquisa tá 77% ou estava tendo
prejuízo ou não tava tendo resultado
desejado Então tava querendo melhorar e
foi a partir dessa pesquisa que eu
também comecei a entender porque as
pessoas não estavam tendo resultado na
sua captação E aí que que a gente
entendeu que a maioria das agências a
maioria dos profissionais que os médicos
estavam contratando eles faziam a
capitação da seguinte
forma
Atração que enviava para um site ou um
WhatsApp e a secretária fazer o
fechamento certo a maioria de vocês é
assim quem for assim Pode mandar aqui é
assim que é o meu é assim que é o meu
pode falar
tá só que que que a gente entendeu a
gente encontrou alguns
problemas dentro desse modelo utilizado
né o primeiro problema é eu atraio
muitas pessoas né Então nesse modelo que
a maioria das agências e profissionais
de tráfego utilizam é eu atraio vários
contatos porém esses contatos são
contatos frios são contatos curiosos são
aqueles contatos que vão perguntar sobre
plano de saúde são aqueles contatos que
vão entrar ali em contato com a sua
secretária no seu WhatsApp vai parar de
responder né então o que seriam contatos
frios são aqueles contatos que talvez
eles tiveram a primeira eh o primeiro
contato com você ou com sua equipe
naquele momento no WhatsApp ou eles te
viram a primeira vez no anúncio Eles não
têm um tempo maior com você e é por isso
que ele é chamado de fro porque ele não
tem
consciência do que você faz ele não tem
consciência de como funciona a sua
consulta ele não tem consciência de como
funciona o seu trabalho e é por isso que
ele é um contato frio e se ele é um
contato frio ele não te valoriza E se
ele não te valoriza ele te ignora ele só
quer saber o preço da sua consulta ele
só quer saber dos planos de saúde tá
porque ele não viu valor no que você faz
Então esse é o primeiro problema que
esse método utilizado pela maioria dos
profissionais e das agências utilizam tá
o segundo problema é que esses
profissionais eles jogam todos os
contatos na mão da secretária E qual é o
problema de você jogar todos os contatos
na mão da secretária O primeiro é que às
vezes ela não vai conseguir dar conta o
segundo é que na maioria das vezes ela
não tem um treinamento adequado ela não
segue um script tá e o terceiro é que
por não conseguir fazer um script
adequado não tem o treinamento de vendas
porque secretária faz uma venda elas não
convertem muito bem e você tem menos
agendamento do que você gostaria e
consequência disso seu faturamento não é
o faturamento que você gostaria no final
do mês
tá e o terceiro problema é que a maioria
de vocês que utilizam esse método
depende unicamente de uma estratégia o
que isso significa essa única estratégia
que eu tô mostrando para vocês nesse
triângulo nesse Triângulo invertido né
nessa pirâmide aqui invertida é que se
essa estratégia por algum motivo parar
de
funcionar vocês de atrair
pacientes vocês param de atrair
pacientes que é a fonte do faturamento
de
vocês então a gente tem três problemas
aqui nesse modelo de hoje tá e eu quero
que agora vocês tomem consciência de
qual é o seu maior problema o maior
problema que vocês têm hoje está nos
contatos que não chegam na secretária de
vocês está na secretária que não
consegue converter em agendamento está
em contatos frios e
desqualificados Ou você tem problema em
todos esses que eu acabei de falar por
que é importante você ter essa
consciência porque eu trago esse essas
perguntas tá porque se você hoje é dono
do seu negócio dono do seu consultório
dono da sua Clínica você precisa saber
onde é que está o problema o por você
não bate metas o por O o seu faturamento
não Onde onde você deseja E para isso
você precisa entender o problema se você
Abandona o problema você não entende
sobre ele você vai continuar tendo o
mesmo problema tá então esse é o momento
onde a gente vai ter a consciência da
onde é que está o nosso problema e
dentro dessa mesma apresentação eu vou
te mostrar como resolver todos eles Tá
certo então vamos lá ó três todos os
problemas todos o quatro né que é tudo
tudo tudo tudo
tudo 2 um e
TR
tá agora voltando as atividades pretend
impar implementar uma captação mais
lógica desde o início quatro tudo tá
então a maioria de vocês está falando
que o problema está em tudo né então
contatos que não estão chegando então
você não tem um número suficiente de
pessoas que chegam na secretária dois
Vocês não tem uma secretária que está
convertendo adequadamente né e
alcançando ali a meta de agendamentos no
mês e vocês também estão tendo contatos
que chegam são contatos frios
desqualificados contatos que não tê
consciência do trabalho que vocês fazem
certo então vamos agora entender como é
que a gente resolve cada um desses
problemas tá a partir disso a gente aqui
entendeu sobre o mundo da Captação
médica a gente entendeu os problemas e a
gente entendeu como reverter esses
problemas Então a primeira coisa que eu
quero que vocês saiam daqui sabendo é
toda captação médica ela precisa ser
individualizada Então pessoal não
adianta replicar estratégia de um outro
médico cada um de vocês vocês são
indivíduos diferentes Tá mesmo que vocês
tenham a mesma especialidade mesmo que
eu esteja falando somente com
ginecologia
somente com geologista somente com
ortopedista cada um de vocês é diferente
vocês têm diferenciais que precisam ser
mostrados para o paciente e é isso que
difere uma estratégia de outra
estratégia então a estratégia para cada
um de vocês é individualizada então não
queiram imitar a estratégia de um outro
colega tá segunda coisa a captação do
médico não pode depender somente de uma
estratégia não pode porque a gente já
viu aqui que se uma estratégia ela para
de funcionar todos os pacientes que
vinham daquela estratégia elas param de
chegar e agora você fica refém
certo então sempre pelo menos duas
estratégias sendo utilizadas para
captação de pacientes tá e terceiro o
médico ele precisa ter um bom sistema de
conversão O que é um sistema de
conversão um sistema de conversão é
aquele sistema que converte contato em
paciente contato em agendamento tá não
adianta eu gerar vários contatos
diariamente para vocês e vocês não terem
um sistema de conversão vocês não terem
uma pessoa que converte em agendamento
tá bom senão isso é dinheiro jogado no
lixo e qual é a melhor forma então da
gente ter muitos contatos chegando e ao
mesmo tempo muito agendamento é quando a
gente tem a estratégia certa uma
estratégia validada para médico aliada
até teologia Por que
tecnologia porque a tecnologia ela
consegue pegar tarefas que a gente faz
diariamente tarefas que a gente faz
repetidamente a gente otimiza o nosso
tempo tá a gente automatiza determinadas
coisas mas sem perder a humanização
Então é isso que eu quero mostrar para
vocês hoje como é que a gente alinha a
nossa estratégia aqui hoje com a
tecnologia é isso que é o método de
agendamento
automático e a partir dessas nossas
descobertas a gente desenvolveu o
primeiro método da Medicina desenvolvida
né Por uma médica que envia pacientes
com data e hora marcada para vocês então
como é que funciona tá aqui eu vou
trazer de uma forma resumida para vocês
depois eu vou explicar cada um dos
Passos como é que funciona eh esse
método primeiro nós temos uma máquina
que é geradora de pacientes particulares
tá então essa máquina ela vai gerar
pacientes diariamente para vocês tá
então essa máquina vai gerar pacientes
diariamente para vocês pacientes
particulares a segunda máquina ela é
responsável por pegar esses contatos que
chegaram e converter esses contatos em
pacientes então uma máquina ataz atrai
os contatos capta os contatos e a outra
converte esses contatos em agendamento
em pacientes e a tenho uma terceira
máquina agora que eu
coloco toda Esse agendamento dentro de
uma agenda e eu faço um fluxo de
acompanhamento com essas pessoas tá não
deixando que essas pessoas sumam não
deixando que essas pessoas não retornem
para minha consulta ou paguem um outro
um procedimento ou um plano de
acompanhamento então eu faço com que
essas pessoas elas têm um contato cada
vez maior com o meu time com a minha
secretária comigo e que elas desejem ter
outros produtos ou que paguem novamente
uma consulta comigo tá bom e o único
trabalho que você vai precisar ter você
como médico dentro desse nosso sistema
dentro desse nosso método é atender o
paciente é a única preocupação que eu
quero que você tenha dentro do nosso
método é atender o paciente que é a
coisa mais importante porque se o seu
tempo está muito dedicado a saber como a
secretária está em você mesmo montar
script para secretária em você mesmo tá
preocupado em gerar pacientes para você
como é que fica o paciente que tá na sua
sala será que você tá dando a devida
atenção para ele então essa é uma
preocupação que nós temos aqui
tá parar ligado na aula é isso
aí tô lendo aqui alguns comentários tá
Nei falou não tenho secretário eu mesmo
falo com paciente Nei você percebe o
quanto isso é um problema porque o seu
tempo que dev deveria estar sendo
dedicado a crescimento do seu negócio ao
tempo com o paciente você tá dedicando
em um trabalho que não deveria ser seu
tá então vamos lá como funciona né de
fato o nosso método de agendamento
automático Então vamos agora para os
detalhes Tá certo
que que a gente tem aqui quando a gente
começa a comparar a nossa inteligência
tá para as agências de Marketing e
gestores de tráfego geral como a nossa
metodologia ela envolve algumas máquinas
de atração de pacientes a gente consegue
atrair muito mais paciente do que uma
agência normal tá certo então se vocês
olharem aqui pro lado esquerdo você vai
ver que a primeira faixinha tá muito
maior do que a primeira baixa do lado
direito consequentemente na parte de
baixo eu tenho mais pessoas entrando em
contato com a secretária tá então se eu
tenho mais pessoas entrando em contato
com a secretária o meu número de
conversão o meu número de agendamento
ele é muito maior por quê quando a gente
tem um funil tá que é como isso aqui que
eu tô mostrando para vocês essa P
divertida é um funil tá no Marketing a
chama isso de um funil Eu tenho pessoas
sendo elas vão se perdendo ao longo do
caminho é normal a gente nunca consegue
ter 100% dos contatos agendados né isso
não existe em lugar nenhum mas se eu
tenho pessoas chegando várias pessoas
chegando com qualidade pelo meu método
de atração e por ter mais de uma
estratégia de atração eu tenho mais
pessoas entrando em contato e eu tenho
mais pessoas agendando e esse é o nosso
grande diferencial em relação às
agências de tráfego que utilizam uma
estratégia e por isso atraem poucos
pacientes poucos pacientes qualificados
e por isso tem menos agendamento
tá E aí que que a gente tem dentro do
nosso método a gente tem fase um fase
dois e fase três a primeira fase é a
nossa fase de atração onde aqui a gente
liga três máquinas ou três estratégias
com o foco em atrair pacientes para
vocês todos os dias para que vocês nunca
dependam somente de uma estratégia Então
sempre que uma por algum motivo tá
funcionando menos a outra tá funcionando
mais se uma para de funcionar a gente já
tem outras duas ligadas atraindo
pacientes para vocês Tá certo eu tenho
na fase dois a conversão onde o meu
principal foco vai ser pegar aqueles
contatos e converter esses contatos em
agendamento aqui dentro né do nosso
método Quem faz isso é a nossa
secretária Lia que é uma inteligência
artificial tá ela é uma secretária
virtual não é um robô é uma inteligência
artificial humanizada e na nossa fase
três a gente tem a fase de fidelização
porque nada adianta pessoal da gente
gastar dinheiro atraindo as pessoas para
dentro do meu WhatsApp para dentro da
minha secretária né eu converter essas
pessoas em agendamento E essas pessoas
vão para minha consulta e acabou não eu
preciso fazer com que essas pessoas se
mantenham dentro do meu negócio ou eu
trago novas ofertas para essa pessoa ou
eu trago para essas pessoas um plano de
acompanhamento mas eu preciso fidelizar
essas pessoas e como é que a gente
fideliza aqui dentro após a pessoa sair
da nossa consulta a gente envia
mensagens perguntando como essa pessoa
está a gente envia mensagem perguntando
como é que tá o tratamento se tá
precisando de alguma coisa você precisa
de um retorno então a gente acompanha
essas pessoas através da nossa
secretária
que também é uma inteligência
artificial Tá
certo então vamos agora paraa nossa
primeira fase que é a fase de
atração hoje nós temos três tipos de
paciente na internet e vocês nunca vão
ouvir isso em lugar nenhum tá porque
isso foi Foi algo que a gente definiu e
criou dentro do nosso método tá E são
três tipos de paciente que a gente criou
com esses nomes de forma didática para
que vocês entendam como é que o
marketing ele funciona também tá a gente
nunca tem somente um tipo de pessoa para
atrair eu quero que vocês entendam que
hoje na internet nós temos três tipos de
paciente que você pode atrair mas a
maioria de vocês atrai somente a
minoria desses pacientes que são os
pacientes urgentes Tá bom então o que
acontece o paciente urgente é aquele
paciente que ele já sabe que ele tem um
problema tá E esse paciente que já sabe
que ele tem um problema ele já vai
procurar vocês ele já vai chegar e
procurar vocês então pode procurar vocês
na internet pode procurar vocês ali no
Instagram no Google pode ligar pede
indicação para alguém esses pacientes já
vão procurar vocês Tá mas eu tenho um
segundo paciente que é o paciente
procrastinador é aquele paciente que ele
sabe que tem um problema porém ele não
busca ajuda ele deixa para depois ele
sabe que ele precisa ir no médico ele
sabe que ele precisa de uma consulta mas
ele deixa para depois tá e o paciente
preventivo é aquele paciente que ele não
tem nenhum problema de saúde aparente
Mas eles ele busca e ele deseja ir no
médico por causa de uma prevenção mesmo
ele quer se prevenir tá então a gente
tem esses três tipos de paciente O que
que a maioria de vocês fazem vocês falam
diretamente com o paciente número um que
esse é paciente urgente só que de acordo
com a nossa pirâmide de acordo com as
nossas pesquisas os pacientes urgentes
os pacientes que determinam ir atrás de
vocês é a minoria eu tenho a maioria dos
outros pacientes eles estão por aí E
eles não são atraídos por
vocês porque vocês não TM uma estratégia
para atrair essas pessoas tá e eu vou
mostrar aqui para vocês como é que vocês
podem fazer Gabriel tá perguntando essa
máquinas São tráfego pago não ficou
Claro Nem todas as nossas máquinas de
atração são tráfego pago tá bom é também
uma parte tráfego pago e a outra não
tá alor Instagram qu V precisar fazer
inst tá essas perguntas eu vou responder
melhor no final tá só pra gente não
perder aqui ainha da apresenta Então
vamos L imag que vocês gravam um anúncio
ou quando vocês se comunicam com o
paciente dessa forma de
Olha se você está passando por isso
talvez seja a consequência desse
problema então se você quiser né
melhorar se você quiser receber um
tratamento adequado marque a sua
consulta todo tipo de anúncio todo tipo
de atração que foca em Marque uma
consulta agende uma consulta vocês estão
falando com a minoria dos pacientes que
estão por aí que são pacientes urgentes
tá então Qual é o tipo de atração Qual é
esse tipo de atração é quando você manda
diretamente para um site quando você
anuncia no Google quando você tá
anunciando pelo meta né que é o
Instagram Facebook eh E você tá falando
de consulta consulta consulta consulta
você está atingindo esse paciente Ou
seja você só tem uma máquina rodando
você só tem uma estratégia rodando e é o
que a maioria faz tá é o que a maioria
faz mas como é que eu atinjo o paciente
procrastinador O que que a gente faz
existe algo dentro do marketing que é
incrível que se chama geração de valor
geração de valor é a melhor forma para
você atrair pessoas cada vez mais
pessoas principalmente a médio e longo
prazo quanto mais valor você gera mais
pessoas você atrá para você mais pessoas
você atrai para você tá E é isso que a
gente faz na nossa máquina dois é a
nossa máquina 1 a gente vai gerar valor
a gente utiliza ebooks a gente utiliza
guias a gente utiliza conteúdos né
escritos tá para passar esse conteúdo
para as pessoas
como ó se eu tô falando aqui com
ortopedista que que a gente pode
fazer eu posso criar um eBook
né ou um guia falando sobre lesões que
podem acontecer dentro da academia né
então eu tenho uma pessoa que tá Tá com
dor lombar depois de
eh alguma algum exercício mal feito né
ali na academia então eu posso trazer
para essa para essa começar a anunciar
para essas pessoas ou outra forma de
passar esse conteúdo para as pessoas
levando um e-book sobre como ela não se
lesionar ou se ela está lesionada depois
de um evento dentro da academia tá então
eu consigo a partir das principais
queixas dos pacientes que eu tenho
dentro do consultório criar guias e
ebooks para entregar para essas pessoas
gerar valor e essas pessoas agendarem
uma consulta Tá bom então é uma forma
que a gente faz aqui que tem muito
resultado e se eu tô falando por exemplo
no paciente preventivo eu posso trazer
um guia eu posso trazer um e-book ali
mais para as pessoas com mais idade como
reduzir a chance de ter artrose né ou
poderia trazer aqui também ah como
reduzir as chances de se lesionar né já
teve um que eu li né não sei se vocês
sabem mas eu eu surfo né então uma vez
eu baixei um e-book sobre como evitar
lesões né no surf e foi algo que para
mim foi essencial então coisas
relacionadas à mobilidade e tudo mais
então são são são é algo que para o
paciente que tá do outro lado é valor o
que você tá gerando tá então existe
exatamente existe uma infinidade de
e-books uma infinidade de guias que você
pode criar para entregar para as pessoas
gerar valor e para que essas pessoas
agendem uma consulta agora vê se você
concorda comigo uma pessoa que veio
agendou uma
consulta essa pessoa veio do ebook essa
é uma p
quente ou seja uma pessoa que conheceu
você quer agendar quer te conhecer ou é
uma pessoa fria n uma pessoa que não tem
ainda consciência do que você faz você
concorda comigo que é uma pessoa quente
porque é óbvio que dentro desse Ebook A
gente não simplesmente passa um conteúdo
ou gera um valor para essa pessoa a
gente fala quem é o médico a gente conta
a história do médico a gente mostra como
funciona funciona a consulta do médico o
que mais esse médico faz Quem esse
médico de ajudou como entrar em contato
com esse médico que agendar alguma
consulta Então são pacientes
extremamente quentes são pacientes que
Muito provavelmente demorem né para para
nunca mais ter uma consulta com você
então são pacientes que vão se tornar
pacientes recorrentes tá E porque você
percebe que já vai filando perfeito
Isaías a gente já vai afunilando a gente
já leva essas pessoas prontas PR gente
dar uma consulta né e é por isso que a
gente isso é uma das das das formas né
do porque a gente diz que a gente leva
paciente com data e hora marcada o
paciente ele já chega pronto então um
dos nossos métodos não é não é
simplesmente a falar com aquele paciente
URG gente e sim falar com paciente
procrastinador e paciente preventivo
passando rápido aqui quando a gente tá
falando de Pediatria então quando eu
quero falar com paciente urgente esse
paciente ele já tem uma dor específica
então eu já falo da dor específica desse
paciente e já envio esse paciente
diretamente para WhatsApp para ele
agendar uma consulta Ok mas se eu tô
falando com paciente procrastinador como
é que eu posso chamar atenção da mãe
porque aqui eu tô falando de Pediatria
então não chama atenção do filho chama
atenção da mãe e do pai então eu posso
falar assim ó seu filho tá chorando
muito essas são uma das principais
causas e o porque você deveria buscar um
médico então entreguei um e-book como
esse máquina três do paciente preventivo
Como prevenir as principais doenças na
criança então aí eu posso Claro ser mais
específica né aqui eu trouxe de uma
maneira mais generalistas para vocês
entenderem Tá bom vamos prosseguir Então
eu imagino que vocês já devem ter
entendido Por que a gente não usa o
modelo tradicional de atração de
pacientes tá a gente utiliza mais de um
tipo de captação mais de uma estratégia
e é por isso que vocês vão atingir
diversos pacientes diferentes isso vai
aumentar o número de pessoas que chegam
no WhatsApp de vocês que chegam na
secretária tá Isso faz parte da nossa
metodologia e quando você tiver essas
máquinas você terá um grande problema
agora que é agora preciso atender de
forma
massiva todas as pessoas que entraram em
contato comigo e qual é o problema que a
gente tem tá porque é humanamente
impossível atender todas as pessoas que
entram em contato com você ao mesmo
tempo porque que acontece Às vezes eu
tenho uma pessoa que tá falando comigo
agora daqui a um minuto eu tenho outra
do minutos eu tenho outra TRS minutos eu
tenho outra e quando eu respondo à
segunda pessoa a primeira já me mandou
uma outra mensagem
então é humanamente impossível tá
e hoje para que a gente tenha um
atendimento eficiente para conseguir
converter essas pessoas em agendamento
eu preciso ter qualidade no meu
atendimento eu preciso ser rápida e
responder todas as pessoas e eu preciso
ter personalização Ou seja a pessoa que
está conversando comigo ela precisa
entender que é uma pessoa precisa
entender que é educada precisa entender
né Precisa ter empatia Então eu preciso
ter uma personalização tá
quando como é que a gente faz a
qualidade né no mundo presencial se eu
tenho uma pessoa presencialmente e você
e essa pessoa precisa atender de 5 a 10
pessoas ela vai atender com qualidade
certo chegaram cinco pessoas 10 pessoas
eu vou atender essas pessoas
tranquilamente eu vou ser Rápida sim eu
consigo ser rápida porque C 10 pessoas
são poucas pessoas eu consigo ter
personalização sim eu consigo ter
personalização né porque eu eu vou
atender aquela pessoa vou atender o meu
paciente de acordo com o que o meu
paciente deseja de acordo com a queixa
que ele tem porque são poucas pessoas
então uma secretária com cinco aou 10
pessoas chegando até ela consegue ter
qualidade rapidez e
personalização Porém quando eu tô
falando de trazer o digital junto para
atrair mais pessoas né e agora eu tenho
10 15 20 30 pessoas chegando 100 pessoas
chegando é o que já aconteceu a minha
qualidade começa a cair se eu tô falando
de uma secretária humana tá muitos aqui
vão até dizer que mesmo com 10 a
qualidade Não não é boa é o que eu ouo
né
Então chegou a esse nível muitas pessoas
chamando ao mesmo tempo secretário
humano não consegue atender com a mesma
qualidade rapidez é impossível ela
digitar para duas pessoas ao mesmo tempo
Quem dirá para 10 15 20 e personalização
que que
acontece quando nós humanos começamos a
conversar com todo mundo aqui já teve um
WhatsApp cheio né de mensagem para
responder quando você tem muita gente
para responder você não responde com
muito com muita empolgação né você só
quer responder logo para finalizar essa
mensagem ir pra próxima finalizar
finalizar a conversa e caminhar né n
então a personalização quem você é na
conversa se perde tá então uma
secretária humana acontece a mesma coisa
o foco dela é eu preciso responder todo
mundo então ela Começa a responder
rápido então começa a comer né comer
letras começa a ser mais ríspida mais
direta ao ponto né e trata Às vezes o
paciente de qualquer jeito
tá então eu quero vocês entendam que às
vezes o problema da secretária de vocês
de não
converter não é o script que elas não
têm que às vezes vocês não entregaram
para ela ou elas não tiveram treinamento
não é a falta de Treinamento você sempre
vai ter um problema com sua secretária
sempre vai ter um problema com sua
secretária Principalmente se o seu
objetivo é ter mais pacientes sendo
agendados você vai ter problema com a
secretária tá esse vai ser sempre o
gargalo porque ela nunca vai conseguir
ter os três critérios juntos qualidade
rapidez e personalização a cada vez que
você aumenta o número de pessoas que
chegam e entram em contato com ela isso
é
impossível e se você não entendeu isso
ainda né que sua secretária ela é
importante estar no
presencial e não atendendo os pacientes
né ali pelo WhatsApp você vai continuar
perdendo paciente você vai continuar
continuar perdendo dinheiro quantos de
vocês aqui já tiveram a secretária que
não conseguiu responder todos os
pacientes ou que respondeu o paciente
respondeu aqueles contatos 1 hora 2
horas Um Dia Depois eu já tive relatos
de alguns clientes nossos que falaram
que a secretárias tinham até que
respondiam duas dois TRS dias depois né
então entendam que é impossível uma
secretária fazer tudo isso e é por isso
que na minha visão secretária ela é
muito importante PR presencialmente para
trazer experiência pro seu paciente né
para est ali presencialmente para
receber o seu paciente tá mas para
atender vários contatos ao mesmo tempo
pode deixar que a inteligência
artificial faz isso e faz muito
bem então a única forma de você ter os
três critérios de atendimento no mundo
online é através da Inteligência
Artificial humanizada E por que
humanizada né talvez vocês falem assim
caramba Inteligência Artificial e
humanização isso é algo muito
contraditório na verdade não é para quem
não entende muito bem da Inteligência
Artificial Nós criamos a inteligência
artificial tá então a inteligência
artificial ela é controlada por humanos
é por isso que eu não vejo a
inteligência artificial como uma ameaça
Então se somos nós que controlamos nós
criamos a inteligência da forma como nós
queremos Então a nossa Inteligência
Artificial Ela já tem um padrão para
atendimentos tá de pessoas Ela já tem um
padrão ela já é empática ela já é
treinada para mundo médico tá E foi por
isso não exatamente mich não é um robô
Essa é a diferença robô ela vai
perguntar para você 1 2 3 Qual número
você quer escolher para receber esse
atendimento você quer falar com
financeiro você quer falar com suporte
você quer falar com isso não é assim a
ela conversa com você tá
certo e agora a gente entra na nossa
segunda fase do método que é conversão
que a gente tem a inteligência
artificial chamada Lia a Lia ela não é
qualquer Inteligência Artificial Como já
antecipei um pouco para vocês ela é uma
inteligência artificial treinada para
converter pacientes para médicos Então
ela já vem com a base de empatia ela já
vem entendendo o que significa um
agendamento ela já vem entendendo
eh algumas queixas de determinadas
especialidades ela é treinada por isso
tá É como se você tivesse A melhor
secretária do mundo não é um robô tá não
fica dando um oi tudo bem para você não
é engessado tá toda a configuração da
Inteligência Artificial é determinada
por você juntamente conosco tá então ela
ela fica da forma como você quer tá
certo ela já é 100% treinada para o
mundo médico então o que que a gente faz
ela já é treinada então toda a base dela
já é treinada para mundo médico só que
lembra que eu falei para vocês que toda
a estratégia Ela é individualizada
independente da especialidade então a
gente entende todo o negócio de vocês
para poder criar uma I individualizado
Tá certo e ela sempre vai tirar o
paciente do ponto que ele está até fazer
o fechamento então a gente já configura
para ela sempre focar no fechamento
particular e além né dela ter uma
conversão muito maior do que uma
secretária humana a Lia ela reconhece
áudio então se você quiser mandar um
áudio paciente mandar um áudio ela
entende o áudio e responde tá E ela
reconhece também documentos e assim que
você finalizar esse paciente ela já vai
enviar direto para a gente
tá e eu quero falar mais uma coisa para
vocês além da gente converter os
pacientes Quantos contatos vocês têm no
WhatsApp de vocês que mandaram mensagem
pra secretária e depois nunca mais foram
contactados ou seja foi um contato que
enviou uma mensagem querendo agendar uma
consulta mas por algum motivo Sea
secretária não conseguiu dar conta ou
respondeu esse paciente não deu
continuidade na conversa e ele não fez o
agendamento
quantas dessas pessoas vocês voltam
voltam atrás Para retomar uma conversa e
fazer o
agendamento fala aqui embaixo por
favor fala aqui embaixo pessoal quantos
de vocês vão atrás daquelas pessoas que
não agendaram consulta ou vocês largam
essas pessoas e não vão mais atrás vocês
pagaram para atrair pacientes e deixaram
os contatos
ali Gabriel vai boa
ah Fran Sérgio não
vai
tá
é
então quase nunca nunca meu Deus gente
às vezes não vou
atrás tá aqui
60% desistem no primeiro contato e você
não vai atrás
Isaías então
aqui ninguém fica para
trás a gente tem aia que com aia você
não vai ter mais esse problema tá se o
paciente ele não fechar ou seja se o
paciente ele não agendar ali ela vai
atrás desses pacientes que não agendaram
só que a gente não vai atrás falando
assim Oi Vamos retomar o contato Oi você
não conseguiu agendar sua consulta Vamos
retomar Vamos agendar uma consulta Não
não é assim n não é aquela coisa de
comercial chato Nada disso lembra que eu
falei geração de valor então é geração
de valor então como é que a gente volta
n a gente vai atrás novamente dess
dessas pessoas que não agendaram
consulta gerando valor pode ser um vídeo
seu pode ser um eBook com um conteúdo
que chame a atenção daquela pessoa n
retomando a conversa de uma forma
interessante até que essa pessoa
vire o seu paciente tá então a gente tem
vários fluxos aqui dentro fazendo com
que a gente retome essas conversas
acompanha esses pacientes Gere valor e
esse paciente se torne realmente ali um
paciente né Ele é agende uma consulta tá
em resumo você terá uma máquina atraindo
muito paciente qualificado e uma outra
máquina que vai atender esse grande
volume melhor do que qualquer humano tá
a nossa terceira fase é a Maria tá a
Maria é uma inteligência artificial que
ela é especialista em sucesso do cliente
eu não sei deixa eu só ligar a luz aqui
que
desligou
foi eu não sei se já ouviram falar sobre
sucesso do cliente mas sucesso do
cliente é como se fosse um suporte mas
que ele é focado para que o seu paciente
tenha sucesso com o tratamento proposto
por você tá então o foco da Maria que é
especialista no sucesso do paciente é
após a consulta a Maria ela entra em
contato com esse paciente
como Oi Fernanda tudo bom O que achou da
consulta e a gente pode né pedir ali
fazer uma pesquisa de satisfação Oi
Maria tudo bom já tem S dias desde a sua
consulta aqui com a gente como é que tá
o tratamento tá com alguma dúvida tá
precisando de alguma coisa tá se
sentindo bem em casos de cirurgias Eu
posso enviar alguns protocolos em caso
de determinadas consultas Eu posso
enviar um e-book com algumas dicas ou eu
posso enviar uma mensagem com algumas
dicas tá Se tiver algum sinal de alarme
que eu preciso precise enviar e avisar
para esse paciente quando buscar um
médico eu aviso também
tá pessoal todas as perguntas que eu não
tô respondendo agora eu vou responder no
final tá então Podem enviar por
aí então que que a gente faz né A partir
de agora ou você continua perdendo os
pacientes ou você começa a utilizar o
primeiro sistema que envia pacientes com
data e hora marcada para você todos os
dias tá então O mais incrível de tudo
isso são os resultados praticamente os
instantâneos que esse método gera tá por
exemplo a gente tem um consultório da
Dra Marcela tá ela é geriatra A consulta
dela é R 400 Eu já falei para ela que Tá
barato então a gente vai aumentar Tá mas
antes ela conseguia gerar 8.200 tá
contatos fazia 754 agendamentos e tinha
243 comparecimentos tá esses dados são
alguns dados também que a gente sempre
traz pra gente ficar olhando e entender
o que que a gente precisa melhorar
dentro da Estratégia proposta tá bom
gerados em 3S meses for 97 97.000 r00 tá
de faturamento tá bom com o nosso método
a d Marcela ela conseguiu
13.254 contatos Então ela aumentou o
número de contatos porque a gente além
de uma estratégia que ela tava
utilizando a gente colocou mais duas
estratégia de captação aumentou o número
de agendamentos para
2098 tá com a inteligência artificial e
teve aí um comparecimento de
1117 tendo gerado aí qu mais de R
400.000 em 3 meses
tá essa outra doutora aqui Estela tô
passando aqui para te agradecer por todo
o cuidado com o resultado que você e sua
equipe tem gerado para a nossa Clínica
Lembra que você tava falando da nossa
reunião que em um mês a Carla e a
estenderam várias Ah uma coisa vocês
podem colocar o nome da da ia de vocês
com qualquer nome tá essa daqui foi
Carla Carla ia está agendando vários
pacientes com o treinamento de vocês
Muito obrigado eu sei que é legal mandar
num grupo com toda a equipe Mas eu
precisava te falar que você tem sido luz
essa semana já foram 15 agendamentos
essa daqui ela
tinha essa daqui ela fazia tipo cerca de
dois agendamentos três agendamentos ali
na semana Lara é impossível fazer 300
consultas no mês mas ela não era sozinha
né ela não era sozinha ela tinha uma
clínica de
geriatria não era sozinha
tem vários clientes aqui que tem vários
profissionais dentro da mesma Clínica e
por qual motivo Hoje os médicos de todo
Brasil tá não somente clínicas né mas
também grandes hospitais estão
utilizando E H humanizada em seu
atendimento tá e deixando a secretária
somente na presencial pessoal foi algo
que já falei para vocês né então a
tendência do mundo hoje é essa então é
muito a escolha de vocês se eu eu vou
junto com a tendência ou eu vou
continuar extremamente tradicional né
não é sobre demitir secretárias não é
sobre isso aqui que eu tô falando é
sobre qual é o a melhor função da
secretária hoje
presencial experiência do cliente tá e
aá fazendo o trabalho mais difícil né
que é fazer aquela parte de atendimento
de várias pessoas né O que que a gente
consegue ganhar ganhar tempo com isso
tá primeira coisa que toda essa galera
todos esses hospitais Eles já entenderam
né que a inteligência artificial é o
futuro na verdade eu até coloquei isso
errado não é o futuro é o presente tá da
Medicina e que se você não utilizar você
vai ficar de fora então eu trouxe aqui
alguns né algumas notícias que já
apareceram né Inteligência Artificial
protagonista revolução sem prescendentes
Na medicina o uso da Inteligência
Artificial na medicina então isso já é
comum tá
segundo eles entenderam que a ia vai
otimizar custos por qu se antes você
precisava ter três C 10 eu vou mostrar
para vocês um vídeo de um médico falando
que ele precisaria de 5 a 10 pessoas
atendendo né 10 secretárias de c a 10
secretárias para conseguir conversar com
todo mundo que chegava tá então você
começa a reduzir os seus custos por eu
não preciso contratar todo mundo eu
tenho uma inteligência artificial que
faz trabalho consegue conversar com
várias pessoas ao mesmo tempo tá então
aqui nessa fintec assistente de a faz o
trabalho de 700 funcionários então aqui
eu tenho aumentar os lucros de 4 40
milhões Então você além de você reduzir
o custo você consegue Óbvio aumentar ali
o seu lucro também utilizando
Inteligência Artificial tá outra coisa
que a gente também tem vários estudos
eles entenderam que uma inteligência
artificial humanizada é a única capaz de
proporcionar tá velocidade então a gente
já tem diversos estudos tá então a gente
tem o MIT né a gente tem Harvest também
falando esse daqui se eu não me engano
era para ter colocado aqui mas esse eu
acho se eu não me engano é o da Velocity
que é no no MIT que que que eles vão
falar falar com o o seu contato né
aquela pessoa que entrou em contato com
você dentro do primeiro minuto aumenta
em 400% a sua conversão tá ou seja aqui
nesse gráfico ele tá mostrando se eu
demoro
3 minutos para entrar em contato com
aquela pessoa que me chamou no WhatsApp
reduz para 98% se eu falo com 1 hora
depois
36% 5 horas depois 24 então começa a
cair drasticamente a minha chance de
fazer um agendamento tá eles entenderam
também que conseguem atender o maior
número de pessoas 200 300 a gente já fez
aqui 300 pessoas simultaneamente tá 300
pessoas
simultaneamente ao mesmo tempo sem
perder a qualidade e aumentar o seu
custo tá então aqui eh a gente tirou um
print lá dentro da da ferramenta tá eh
de respostas né em tempo real então
todos os seus contatos vão ser
respondidos à medida que eles foram
enviando mensagem certo então em tempo
real eles perceberam também né que a ia
ela consegue atender sim melhor do que
um ser humano Porque a gente já entendeu
que para um bom atendimento eu preciso
de qualidade rapidez e personalização se
eu tenho várias pessoas na fila para eu
conversar eu um ser humano eu vou perder
a minha personalização com tempo certo
então a i ela tem sim a sensibilidade
porque a gente deixou ela sensível então
aqui foi um caso né de um paciente que
enviou a mensagem avisando que
precisaria remarcar a consulta porque
teve um imprevisto esse imprevisto foi
uma pessoa da família faleceu e essa foi
a resposta da Inteligência Artificial
sinto muito pela sua perda Gustavo
minhas condolências a você e a sua
família nesse momento difícil se
precisar de ajuda ou quiser agendar a
consulta em um outro momento estarei
aqui para ajudar então isso foi a
resposta da Inteligência Artificial ela
entende áudio situações delicadas e
consegue converter melhor do que a gente
tá eu não sei se eu conseguiria escrever
algo tão bom quanto
ela então esse atendimento ele é
personalizado e individual para cada
pessoa tá ou seja tem personalização de
acordo com o que deseja e de acordo com
a sua dor Tá certo então aqui tem
algumas dos prints que a gente tirou
dentro do nosso sistema tá de algumas
inteligências dos nossos clientes tá
esse caso aqui foi uma eh de terapia
capilar
Tá então não tem risco trabalhista Esse
é um bom bom motivo não tem dia ruim
então a yar não vai chegar para você ó
Doutor hoje eu não vou conseguir tá você
não precisa pagar 13 tá Ou seja a
inteligência artificial ela pode sim
trabalhar para você 24 horas por dia 7
dias por semana e ainda ela será muito
mais eficiente e ela não te dar
desculpas para trabalhar que que é
importante falar para vocês também ela
necessariamente precisa atender 24 horas
Se você quiser sim se você não quiser
você configura o tempo que você quiser
tá você que determina isso e melhor de
tudo conversando com grandes
instituições e hospitais eles trouxeram
esses dados
tá secretária humana qualidade de
atendimento nota 6.2 quem é que dava né
quem é que dá essa nota os próprios
pacientes tá ali para pesquisa de
satisfação e secretária com o ia a
qualidade de atendimento subiu para
9.4 surpresa
eu também
fiquei e o principal que eles entenderam
É que diminui os custos diminui
colaboradores tem mais
eficiência você vai ter você teria que
ter no mínimo 10 a 20 secretárias
humanas né E podendo ainda não ser
iguais ali em relação à qualidade e
rapidez como as ias humanizadas tá então
eu sei que isso é algo novo para vocês
eh mas é muito importante eu trazer
esses dados para que vocês
entendam esse novo mundo que está na
frente de vocês tá e eu vou te mostrar
ela funcionando na prática agora tá o
que que eu vou fazer aqui eu vou
compartilhar a minha tela com vocês Tá
deixa eu
só lembrar como é que eu faço isso
pera
aí pera
aí
lembrei sai não pessoal que agora vocês
vão ver ela
funcionando só um
minuto vamos lá vocês estão vendo minha
tela agora
né pronto eu não tô vendo vocês tá vamos
lá essa aqui é Laí tá como eu falei para
vocês a gente colocou na apresentação A
Lia e a Maria Certo mas vocês podem
chamar ela do nome que vocês quiserem
essa daqui é Laí tá vou mandar
Oi Vi um Oi vi um anúncio e gostaria de
marcar uma consulta com o
or
ortopedista é importante falar para
vocês que essa daqui a gente configurou
para ortopedista tá para um cliente
nosso Então esse é o foco
dela vamos esperar
vocês estão conseguindo ver minha
tela ó ela tá digitando Vocês conseguem
ver então que ela ela é configurada para
mostrar pro paciente que ela tá
digitando alguns de vocês vão perguntar
também ah por Demorou alguns segundos
para responder gente para também não
parecer que é um robô tá então até o
tempo de resposta a gente configura
também Oi sou Laí da equipe do Dr João
Nunes como posso te ajudar hoje Qual o
seu nome por favor Estela
vamos
lá eu não tô conseguindo
ver o que vocês estão mandando no chat
tá porque eu tô com a tela compartilhada
então depois que eu descompartilhar eu
mostro aí para vocês tá
bom tá vendo tá aparecendo de
novo você poderia me contar um pouco
mais sobre o que você tá buscando ou
qual problema de saúde você gostaria de
consultar com Dr João assim eu consigo
entender melhor como ele pode ajudar tá
vamos
lá estou
Opa
estou estou com dor na
lombar foi pois
não
queda queda minha internet tá um pouco
lent então foi após uma
queda no
futv isso aqui é real tá pessoal eu tive
sérias dores lombares depois de uma
queda no fot volley vamos lá
ó Sinto muito em saber sobre a sua dor
na lombar Estela Então ela já Segurou o
nome tá isso é muito importante sempre
chamar o paciente pelo nome isso pode
ser bastante desconfortável
especialmente após uma queda o Dr João
Nunes tem bastante experiência em tratar
essas questões utilizando abordagens
personalizadas para cada paciente a
consulta é bem detalhada e o Dr João
dedica um tempo especial para entender
todos os aspectos no seu caso Vamos
agendar um horário que você possa ser
avaliada ele costuma ter uma agenda bem
concorrida que que a gente faz aqui a
gente sempre coloca escassez no momento
de falar os horários disponíveis então a
gente geralmente coloca dois horários e
pede pro paciente escolher tá então que
tal conferir algumas opções podemos
agendar segunda-feira às 14 ou
quarta-feira às 17 que que eu vou fazer
eu vou mandar um áudio tá com meu
celular falando que eu não posso
abrir aqui que eu não posso nenhum
desses
horários Oi Laí tudo bem eu não consigo
nenhum desses horários teria alguma
disponibilidade na terça-feira à
tarde vamos ver
ó Ela ouviu que eu perguntei Oi Laí tudo
bem Ela falou lá Estela tudo bem
Obrigada por perguntar entendi que os
horários que sugiri não funcionam para
você
como a agenda do Dr João é bem disputada
No momento tenho disponível na
terça-feira às 15 ou na quinta-feira às
18 qual dessas opções você prefere assim
garantimos que você fique sem horário Tá
eu vou deixa eu digitar
aqui tá terça às 15
horas
está ótimo
pera
aí está
ótimo
pera já já vou perguntar o preço da
consulta
tá eu não tô conseguindo ver agora mas
vão me mandando aí o que que vocês estão
achando tá que assim que eu sair daqui
da tela compartilhada eu vou ler com
vocês vamos falando
aí ótimo Estela vou confirmar seu
agendamento para a terça
às cond João Nossa Clínica fica na rua
Se você precisar de mais alguma
informação ou tiver alguma dúvida Anes
da consulta só me avisar tá
Qual o
preço
com então vocês perceberam também que em
nenhum Aí ela falou o preço da consulta
sem eu perguntar tá porque muitas
pessoas falam logo o valor da consulta
isso assusta o paciente não então ela
sempre vai focar em perguntar o nome
para sempre conversar com a pessoa
falando o nome ela vai depois entender
Qual é o motivo né pelo qual aquela
pessoa está querendo fazer o agendamento
para que ela pegue esse motivo e
transforme aquilo em algo paraa pessoa
agendar tá o valor da consulta é r$ 400
Ele oferece um atendimento exclusivo e
personalizado avaliando com atenção
todos os aspectos do seu caso o
pagamento pode ser feito no dia da
consulta no consultório se estiver tudo
bem para você Posso confirmar o seu
agendamento para terça-feira à 15 que
que é legal em falar aqui também tem
alguns clientes nossos que eles col eles
pedem para ter o pagamento antecipado
então é aqui que a gente vai enviar
também o link da antecipação tá ou o
piix Tá
certo eu vou assim achei
caro atende
portano vão colocando aqui no chat
pessoal O que que você estão achando
porque eu quero saber o que vocês estão
achando tá quero entender se vocês estão
gostando tá vamos botando aí assim que
eu sair daqui dessa tela vou olhar ó O
valor é uma preocupação comum e posso
esclarecer que o Dr João não atende por
plano de saúde pois ele prioriza a
qualidade do atendimento dedicando cerca
de 60 a 70 minutos a cada paciente o que
geralmente não é viável nos atend entos
por convênio Então olha o que a ia fez
ela não respondeu simplesmente que o Dr
João não atende por plano tá ela disse
que não atende mas mostrou o diferencial
do porque ele não atende porque ele
prioriza o particular porque a atenção
dele vai ser maior para aquele paciente
tá o foco é oferecer um atendimento
detalhado e humanizado buscando
resultados duradouros para você Que tal
reservarmos um horário para que você
possa conhecer essa abordagem
pessoalmente podemos manter a opção para
terça às 15 ou discutir uma outra data
que lhe seja conveniente tá então
podemos confirmar
sim
tá então vou fechar
aqui deixa eu
interromper voltar para
apresentação e olhar
o
chat Maurício sensacional Carmen estou
achando bom eu acho ótimo esse
atendimento como fazer quando a clínica
atende além de particulares atende
Convênio vai ser configurada para
aceitar particular e atender Convênio Só
que que que a gente sempre recomenda
aqui dentro tá Antônio o particular ele
tem diferenciais que o convênio não tem
e isso a inteligência artificial deixa
bem claro isso então no caso se fosse o
Dr João que aceitasse plano ele falar
aceita o plano porém no plano nós não
temos certos eh diferenciais é como a
gente tem no particular que são esses
daqui tá FT que eu não não sei quem não
me perguntou é possível adição a
prontidão do atendimento é ótimo contudo
para quem atende uma classe mais
privilegiada sim tá É possível adição
isso aqui que eu mostrei para vocês é
uma inteligência artificial que a gente
deixou pronta para Dr João que é o
ortopedista que a gente tem aqui dentro
tá porém ela não é engessada se Dr João
falar assim Estela não quero que seja
dessa forma eu quero enviar um link de
pagamento antes eh eu quero que fale
mais um texto maior sobre os meus
diferenciais sobre as outras coisas que
eu ofereço dentro da minha consulta vai
ser falado Tá
bom então vamos lá
pessoal eh eu que sou médica eu tô em
todos os em vários congressos de
Tecnologia de saúde né eles falam que
essa é a nova revolução da Medicina e
que vocês que estão aqui estão podendo
fazer parte dessa Nova Era tá eu tenho
Certeza certeza certeza que 2026
2027 a maioria das pessoas vão estar
usando isso só que isso aqui vai se
tornar cada vez mais caro tá hoje como
são poucas pessoas que fazem poucas
pessoas que que
tem então é mais tranquilo e agora eu
quero entender se você deseja saber como
implementar todo esse
sistema em sua Clínica ou em seu
consultório e fazer parte dessa nova
revolução em 2025 parar de perder
agendamentos parar de perder dinheiro e
tem uma máquina né que de fato agenda
para você tá então como é que funciona
aqui dentro Primeiro me fala aqui se
vocês querem querem entender como
implementar isso aqui na clínica de
vocês me fala é preciso saber se vocês
realmente querem
né quero
quero Gostaria muito de saber
como desejo saber como farer isso com
vocês sim sim sim claro claro quero
massa
vamos
lá que que a gente tem aqui nós dentro
da nossa implementação temos quatro
fases tá a fase de análise então uma das
pessoas aqui perguntou Ah como é que
vocês vão individualizar para cada
pessoa é nessa fase de análise que a
gente tem de todos o negócio de vocês
então o que que vocês fazem paciente
vocês querem atrair Como funciona essa
consulta se vocês têm outros serviços
outros procedimentos quais os
diferenciais e a gente vai montar a
inteligência artificial de vocês baseado
nos no que vocês trouxerem pra gente na
segunda fase é a fase que a gente vai
construir todas as suas estratégias de
atração de pacientes tá vamos construir
todos os seus e-books todos os seus
guias na fase três a gente vai construir
cada uma das suas inteligências
artificiais Então a gente vai ter a
nossa inteligência de conversão que o
foco é pegar os contatos e converter em
agendamento em pacientes e aqueles
pacientes que já passaram pela consulta
fidelizar com um fluxo de acompanhamento
tá bom e depois a gente tem a fase
quatro que é melhoria contínua onde a
gente coleta todos os dados mensalmente
E cria um plano de ação para o próximo
mês tá certo o objetivo é que você ten
uma máquina de pacientes particulares
com data e hora marcada todos os dias
então a gente tem a fase de análise que
é onde a gente vai ter todas as
informações sobre o seu negócio que você
quer que a inteligência artificial saiba
é por isso que essa inteligência que eu
passei para vocês né ela conseguiu
responder muito bem porque ela entende
sobre as as principais queixas que Dr
João atende se eu falasse outro outra
queixa ela entenderia também porque a
gente passa para ela o que o o que Dr
João vz diariamente no consultório tá
depois da fase de análise a gente
implementa todas as suas máquinas tá
então eu e minha equipe que fazemos isso
e por fim você vai ter uma máquina
agendamento automático pronta Então você
tem atração de pacientes você tem
agendamento E você tem a fidelização
tá então como é que funciona né toda
essa parte de Diagnóstico individual
então na primeira fase do projeto vocês
entrando com a gente a primeira coisa
que a gente faz é fazer um diagnóstico
individual estratégico com cada um de
vocês tá então a nossa equipe né os
nossos coordenadores de a atração eles
vão entender quem são vocês Qual é sua
área qual tipo de paciente você deseja
quais as dores do seu público o que você
deseja
eh ter dentro das suas máquinas entendeu
então a gente faz todo esse diagnóstico
após a gente entender o que que vocês
precisam A gente desenvolve todos os
seus guias para atrair esses pacientes e
ajudar na fidelização tá E além disso
algo que eu não falei durante a
apresentação é que quando você tem guias
e você tem e-books né rodando com o seu
nome você tá elevando né Tá propagando o
seu nome ou seja você tá crescendo a sua
marca pessoal que isso ao longo do tempo
é incrível porque vai chegar um momento
onde você começa a ter mais indicações
também mas você não dependerá delas Tá
certo se você fosse pagar um um
profissional para fazer cada um desses
guias você pagaria R 1.000 para fazer
cada guia desse eu sei disso porque eu
já paguei um profissional para fazer
isso
tá você vai ter a cada 30 dias um
laboratório de análise com os nossos
especialistas tá A cada 30 dias que a
gente vai analisar como está a sua
atração então quanto Eh quantas pessoas
estão sendo atraídas e também para
analisar sua máquina de conversão então
quantas pessoas estão sendo atraídas
quantas pessoas estão sendo agendadas
quantas pessoas estão comparecendo se eu
tô conseguindo vender outros
procedimentos serviços protocolos planos
após a minha consulta
tá a gente vai ter também a cada 15 dias
tutorias estratégicas sobre marketing
também tá e a gente vai construir a sua
máquina de atração Então a nossa equipe
ela vai construir toda a sua máquina
dentro do seu consultório Então você vai
ter uma máquina de pacientes sem uma
máquina que vai atrair pacientes todos
os dias para você tá e você não vai
precisar fazer nada nunca mais você vai
precisar depender de plano de saúde a
não ser que você queira tá que tá tudo
bem também vamos implementar o seu
sistema de conversão Então você terá a
melhor secretária do mundo dentro do
Meio médico dentro do seu consultório
que é treinada de acordo com as suas
informações que vai pegar todos esses
pacientes agendados e vai colocar dentro
da agenda certo nós temos também o nosso
sistema de fidelização que eu falei que
a gente faz aqui hoje com a Maria mas
você vai escolher o nome que você quiser
que faz com que os seus pacientes eles
fiquem Apaixonados Pela experiência da
sua consulta tá bom e isso vai gerar
indicação para você porque o cuidado que
você gera o cuidado que você tem com
aqueles pacientes que passaram por uma
consulta faz com que eles queiram
indicar você para outras pessoas
tá então o que que as agências te
entregam tráfego site e Envia essas
pessoas para WhatsApp O que que a gente
te entrega a gente entrega pacientes
prontos com data e hora marcada então a
gente entrega três máquinas de atração
de pacientes onde a gente atrai paciente
urgente paciente procrastinador e
paciente preventivo todos esses
pacientes caem dentro de uma
inteligência artificial que o objetivo
que ela tem é converter esses contatos
em
agendamentos tudo isso é levado para
dentro de uma agenda e após essa
consulta acontecer a gente tem a Maria
que é uma inteligência artificial
responsável por fidelizar aqueles
pacientes que passaram por você mas
aqueles pacientes né aqueles contatos
que não agendaram consulta mas que
chegaram no seu WhatsApp Alia a nossa
Inteligência Artificial vai entrar em
contato Para retomar até um agendamento
Tá
certo e eu quero mostrar aqui um
depoimento alguns depoimentos das
pessoas que já estão aqui dentro com a
gente tá vou dar um que vocês atuam Na
verdade eu acho que eu precisaria de
quatro a cinco boas empresas empresa e e
e recepcionista né Eu precisaria de
quatro a cinco boas empresas fazendo
isso assim para nível de complexidade
que vocês atingiram realmente é eu não
tinha visto nada perto disso parabéns
porque realmente hoje é o melhor serviço
que eu já vi igual você falou que porque
não vai depender outro ah gerar
posicionamento e tudo beleza aí você vai
lá aí você vai ter que ter um tempo você
vai ter que gravar não sei quantos
vídeos vai ter que mudar uma postura
interna tem pessoas que vai demorar se
meses um ano para conseguir fazer uma
uma coisa dessa e não vai voltar não vai
conseguir vender mais imediatamente que
às vezes vai ter uma secretária e tudo
mais esse serviço de vocês é sensacional
Bruno parabéns então como eu ainda tô
começando e isso aqui me ajudou assim eu
não sei nem o que dizer só elogiar
porque é uma pessoa falando aqui né eu
eu tô impressionada nível tá coisa meio
e já sa né própria isso e não é o que tá
aparecendo aqui a gente lê parece que é
uma pessoa que tá
interagindo
massa Deixa eu voltar aqui pra
apresentação então vocês viram aí são
duas pessoas tá que a gente colocou
aqui que uma ela falou que precisaria de
cinco a 10 pessoas para atender a
quantidade de pessoas necessárias né
contatos e a gente tem a outra que não
acreditou que o que a gente tinha
entregado para ela era uma inteligência
artificial atendendo os pacientes tá
porque ela achou que tinha um nível tão
grande de humanização que não poderia
ser uma inteligência artificial
tá então o melhor disso tudo é que o que
a gente tá passando aqui para vocês o
que eu tô mostrando aqui para vocês a a
gente garante dentro de um contrato a
gente confia tanto nesse nosso sistema
tanto no nosso método que a gente te dá
garantia em contrato dos resultados que
a gente gera e como é algo muito
individual né algo que individualizado
em todas as fases a gente não consegue
atender todo mundo tá então eu quero que
vocês que T interesse né E tem vontade
de entrar nesse novo mundo tá que tá
gerando bastante dadoo clique aqui
embaixo tá no botão que vai
aparecer e preenche o formulário é com
esse formulário que a gente vai entender
se o seu consultório a sua Clínica está
preparado para implementar a nossa
Inteligência Artificial aqui embaixo tem
um botãozinho verde que fala agendar
análise de implementação você vai
conversar comigo ou com um dos nossos
especialistas aqui dentro e vai entender
como funciona a todos os nossos sistemas
vai entender como funciona toda a nossa
entrega e vai entender se faz sentido
pro seu consultório ou pra sua cía ter
aqui né a nossa Inteligência Artificial
então clica aqui embaixo tá nós como é
algo individualizado a gente não
consegue atender todo todo mundo tá bom
então clica aqui embaixo Lara você vai
passar os valores dentro da reunião a
gente passa todos os valores tá Lar a
gente precisa entender melhor sobre você
precisa entender melhor sobre sua
clínica
se é só você se tem várias pessoas tá
bom responde o formulário é um
formulário muito rápido porque a gente
precisa conhecer vocês antes da da
reunião tá bom E vocês vão entender como
funciona ainda melhor do que eu mostrei
aqui nessa apresentação para vocês
tá eu queria saber você disse que eu não
preciso gravar conteúdo mas e os
anúncios como serão feitos então Gabriel
a gente tem algumas coisas né a gente
para a gente anunciar por exemplo no
Google eu não preciso de nenhum vídeo tá
se eu for anunciar ali para dentro do
meta eu posso utilizar imagem Ou posso
utilizar vídeo o vídeo não
necessariamente é um conteúdo tá então a
maior parte aqui dos nossos clientes
eles têm resultado dentro do Google tá
certo não precisa produzir conteúdo
em quanto tempo teremos relação quanto
tempo Já teremos retorno em relação à
marcação e agendamento de pacientes quem
foi que perguntou Larissa então Larissa
tudo isso aqui que eu mostrei para você
isso é criado em 25 dias isso é entregue
para você em 25 dias a partir dos 25
dias já tá funcionando todos seus sua
seu sistema de atração de paciente e
todo o seu sistema é de agendamento né
sua inteligência artificial com 25 dias
já tá pronto na sua mão tá isso a gente
tudo tem dentro de contrato
também pessoal quem tem dúvida vai
mandando aqui mas quem quer conhecer a
inteligência artificial né quer entender
melhor ainda como ela funciona clica
aqui no botão verdinho para vocês
conversarem com a gente
tá se o como funciona esses
ebooks Silmara esses ebooks a gente que
cria para vocês tá o único trabalho que
vocês vão precisar ter com esses ebooks
é ler o que a gente criou tá só para
confirmar se tá tudo de acordo e com o
que vocês estavam imaginando que a gente
iria criar tá Esses e-books são
ah como é que eu posso explicar para
você Digamos que é um PDF tá com design
né todo elaborado que a gente fala um
pouco sobre você só que a gente foca em
uma queixa do seu paciente né então ah
qual é a queixa principal que o seu
consultório atende hoje então a gente
vai pegar essa queixa a gente vai criar
um conteúdo né um texto em PDF e a gente
vai prepará-lo para você só que dentro
desse PDF A gente vai falar um pouco
sobre você sobre a sua experiência os
resultados que você gerou pros pacientes
tá E é assim que a gente deixa pronto e
envia para
você já Jaqueline perguntou qual o valor
desse serviço
Jaqueline clica aqui embaixo no botão
verde preenche o formulário você vai
marcar uma reunião comigo ou com a minha
equipe a gente vai te falar do preço só
que a gente vai te falar da nossa
entrega o que que a gente faz Existe
Diferença de preço de acordo com o fluxo
todos esses fluxos que eu enviei para
você tá dentro do que a gente entrega tá
Jaqueline também perguntou seria para
cada médico da Clínica ou
individualmente
a a gente vai precisar entender sobre
isso tá
bom fiquei muito interessado então afr
clica aqui embaixo no botão verde
preenche formulário e Agenda uma reunião
com a gente
tá quanto tempoa essa fase de
análise você entra tá você vai vai
participar dessa reunião diagnóstico e
nessa reunião de Diagnóstico a gente vai
pedir para você responder tá algumas
perguntas e Ness com essas perguntas a
gente vai treinar a inteligência
artificial com até 10 dias úteis a gente
já te entrega a primeira versão dessa
Inteligência Artificial tá para já ir
testando e para você ver o que que você
achou tá
Larissa perguntou e para médicos que
estamos estão começando e que ainda não
tem paciente Larissa você concorda
comigo se você ainda não tem paciente
você precisa atrair pacientes então
funciona para você também porque a gente
vai
criar toda a fase né estratégia de
atração para você então a gente vai
levar pacientes para você então se você
não tem pacientes você vai começar a ter
pacientes e você vai precisar de qu né
então acredito que se você esteja
começando você não tem ainda uma pessoa
que faça ali os seus agendamentos e a
gente vai te entregar também uma
inteligência artificial que vai fazer
esses agendamentos para você tá dentro
tudo isso dentro de um sistema então
você não precisa também pagar outro
sistema tá você já vai ter acesso a tudo
isso Michele perguntou isso é feito em
Call sim Michele tudo isso é feito em
Call então a distância entre nós não é
problema nenhum tá bom
Silmara perguntou primeiro atendimento é
presencial não Silmara Mas se a gente
tiver na mesma cidade a gente pode se
encontrar sim
tá sim eu quero entender como funciona o
trabalho de vocês Joseane falou Joseane
então clica aqui no botão tá para
agendar uma reunião com a gente
uhum tem interesse quero saber mais
Jaqueline você falou que tem interesse
clica aqui no botão
tá eu tô subindo aqui para ler mais as
perguntas de
vocês e que falou ó tem um compromisso
agora mas aguardo sua I para me captar
depois Antônio perguntou é possível no
atendimento dirigir a inteligência
artificial
para convênios ou particulares Não
entendi muito bem sua pergunta mas se
for o que eu tô pensando sim tá a gente
tem pessoas aqui dentro médicos aqui
dentro que atendem convênio e
particulares tá E aí a gente só precisa
diferenciar o que tem né na consulta do
convênio que tem na consulta particular
fazer a diferenciação e mostrar isso
para paciente sem problema nenhum
tá nereid falou Gostaria muito de saber
como só clicar aqui no botão verdinho
preencher o formulário que você vai ter
uma reunião comigo ou com a minha equipe
você vai entender exatamente como fazer
Rafaela perguntou a oferece planos de
tratamento por exemplo acompanhamento
sobrepeso obesidade vocês trabalham
dessa forma raa a gente pode sim
para oferecer os planos de
acompanhamento tá os planos de
tratamento certo não tem problema que
que é importante eu falar para vocês tá
a gente pode colocar a para fazer o que
a gente quiser então se eu falar ó Eu
quero que você venda isso eu quero que
você venda esse protocolo eu quero que
você venda esse tratamento quero que
você venda esse serviço eu quero que
você faça essa oferta ela vai fazer tá
porém eu não recomendo que você ofereça
planos de tratamento ou plano de
acompanhamento ou
protocolos dentro de uma conversa de
WhatsApp Isso deve ser feito no olho a
olho com o paciente tá ou se você né ou
presencialmente ou durante a consulta
online tá isso deve ser feito por você e
não por nenhuma secretária tá porque o
paciente ele precisa ver valor naquilo
que você tá falando como é um plano ele
geralmente é algo mais caro do que uma
própria consulta é você que tem que
fazer essa venda tá certo mas a gente
tem
eh paci pacientes ó a gente tem clientes
aqui que vendem planos de tratamento
planos de acompanhamento e que que a
gente faz a gente
antecipa o que são esses planos antes da
consulta porque foi um uma coisa que o
médico ele pediu ele falou assim Estela
eu quero que a gente
antecipe que né eu vou oferecer isso na
minha consulta então eu quero que a
gente fale um pouco sobre esse plano
dentro ali do agendamento pode ser pode
ser a gente falou para Iá falar
exatamente que tinha um plano né que o
doutor poderia oferecer durante a
consulta e explicar o que que era tá
então a gente pode fazer isso sim mas
caso você queira vender dentro da
Inteligência tudo bem eu não recomendo
tá não porque ela não vai saber fazer
ela vai fazer vai saber fazer mas a
conversão através de você vai ser muito
maior tá por qu pessoas se conectam né
vendo as outras pessoas então fica mais
fácil Luiz falou preciso saber como vou
atrair pacientes se eu não uso rede
social você não precisa de rede social
para atrair né então se a gente falar de
rede social rede social como Facebook
tiktok Instagram você não precisa você
pode simplesmente utilizar o Google
tá
a tá configurada para atender todas as
especialidades Sim porém a gente
configura ela de acordo com as suas
individualidades Tá certo
Viviane perguntou e quando o cliente é
daquelas pessoas que escrevem tudo
errado sem pontuação com muito erros de
ortografia e a consegue compreender e
seguir com atendimento eficaz Consegue
sim tá aa consegue entender Marcinho
falou Eu gostei demais da i
essa aqui já
respondi
Hum tô subindo toda a conversa porque
Vocês perguntaram Tô respondendo
aqui e quando a pessoa que está tentando
marcar consulta já é paciente da Clínica
como ficaria essa marcação a gente
configura para perguntar se é a primeira
cons se é já é paciente da Clínica tá
jaquelin é bem tranquilo fazer isso a
gente inclusive fez isso
pr pra valdin que apareceu no no
depoimento Jaqueline falou também muitos
marcam e não vão simplesmente faltam o
paciente não devia pagar antecipado para
reservar um horário Jaqueline em relação
a pagar antecipado isso vai de acordo
com o médico tá nesse caso do João
não é algo que o João faz tá a gente até
conversou sobre essa estratégia para ele
e Ah o que foi definido a gente testaria
assim mas depois a gente passaria um mês
testando com o pagamento antecipado e
depois a gente ia ia olhar os dois meses
Como foi o meu faturamento com o
pagamento antecipado E como foi o meu
mês sem o pagamento antecipado tá por o
mais importante de tudo são os dados que
a gente vai ter no final tá Então a
partir daí a gente vai ver o que que
mais funciona e vai focar naquilo que
mais funciona eu tenho clientes aqui que
pegam pagamento tesado e tenho clientes
que não pegam pagamento antecipado tá e
dá para fazer das duas
formas e quando só querem saber o valor
da consulta Larissa perguntou Então se
eles só querem saber o valor da consulta
a gente Primeiro vai dizer quais são os
diferenciais que existem na minha
consulta Então por da consult O que que
a consulta faz o que que a gente entrega
lá dentro que não é simplesmente uma
consulta e depois a gente fala o preço
tá Mas a gente sempre configura e a para
entender qual é o problema e por aquela
pessoa tá buscando tá então assim
funciona muito
mais Marcinho Ela escuta áudio escuta
áudio Você viu que escutou o meu né Tá
ao vivo
então não tem como né esconder
Marcinho Minha secretária nem
responder José Pessoa minha secretária
Nunca faria isso já falaria o valor Isso
é
incrível
Larissa às vezes um parente que entra em
contato para marcar consulta daí Larissa
que que a gente pode fazer no fluxo tá a
gente pode configurar o fluxo para
seguir da seguinte forma a pessoa ela
pede para marcar a consulta né aí a
gente pede lá nome tudo mais e a gente
pergunta a consulta é para você ou é
para uma outra pessoa então a gente pode
configurar
tá Fran Sérgio falou caramba A Iá tá
respondendo 9 horas de um domingo à
noite como eu falei para vocês a gente
pode configurar qualquer horário tá
então pode responder final de semana tá
fora do horário
comercial que
legal Beatriz perguntou também sobre
antecipação de pagamento já
respondi geralmente aqui né pros
clientes que a gente tem eles solicitam
20% tá do valor da consulta Não sei se
isso foi dúvida de alguém mas já
antecipando
aqui Jaqueline perguntou caso os médicos
de uma clínica tenham valores de
consultas diferentes como seria esse
agendamento
Jaqueline se eu tenho vários médicos
diferentes aí ela vai saber que existem
médicos diferentes tá eu posso ter
também especialidades diferentes então
aí ela vai marcar de acordo com o médico
e se o pagamento for feito
presencialmente a pessoa já vai est
agendada e a pessoa ela vai pagar
presencialmente
senão se ela falou ah Quero marcar com o
Dr João que é o Ortopedista e custa R
400 então a i vai enviar o link de Dr
João
tá Rita Tenho dificuldades em saber a
utilização em clínica multidisciplinar
não tem problema a gente atende aqui
e várias clínicas que tem vários
profissionais de várias especialidades
diferentes atende do mesmo
jeito ris falou pelo que eu estou
entendendo eu só vou precisar de uma
recepcionista para a chegada do paciente
exatamente ris
exatamente muita gente coloca a
secretária como
recepcionista na minha visão secretária
a experiência ali do paciente que acabou
de chegar tá atendimento Inteligência
Artificial caramba eu subi tanto
Que você estão mandando mensagem aqui
embaixo não
vi isas perguntando como que os
pacientes vão conseguir entrar em
contato com minha
secretária então Isaías qualquer forma
de atração de pacientes vai levar essas
pessoas para WhatsApp tá bom qualquer
atração qualquer atração Digamos que
você tem um cão deit
cartão de visita Você tem o número de
WhatsApp esse número de WhatsApp vai
cair na secretária
virtual Digamos que você fez um anúncio
no Google que né Caiu no WhatsApp tá
falando com a
secretária Telma falou Eu agendei uma
reunião Parabéns Telma vocês entrarão em
contato com certeza tá a gente vai
entrar em contato Pode ficar tranquila
qual ser forma da reunião Meet tá vai
ser o Meet o Google
Meet ris falou não consigo agendar a
análise travou no dia 9 ô r você pode
tentar novamente por
favor tô falando aqui com a equipe para
liberar os outros dias
Mirtes falou não consegui chegar no
início preciso se possível saber as
informações iniciais M faz assim clica
aqui no botão verde agenda a sua análise
tá aqui tudo que foi falado né O que o
que você não ouviu aqui a gente pode
falar dentro da análise para você ficar
tranquilo
tá então anúncio no Google será parte ou
vocês também tomam conta disso a gente
toma conta disso tá
lembra que eu falei para vocês que a
gente enta o paciente com data e hora
marcada a gente fica
responsável o número de WhatsApp precisa
ser diferente do número do WhatsApp da
minha secretária não precisa
Jaqueline Yuri aá fará o followup de
pacientes Sim qual a duração você e a
gente juntos a gente que determina tá
bem
só tem disponibilidade de 10 gente a
gente eu tô pedindo para abrir mais
agenda tá porque vocês estão lotando
agenda
aqui tô falando aqui com
eles Gilson faz
análise Cátia eu vou pedir paraa equipe
falar com você tá
cá todo mundo que
agendou todo mundo que agendou a gente
vai entrar em contato pode ficar
tranquilo tá para lembrar do horário
para enviar o link da
reunião josan falou dentro do trabalho
de vocês também tem a máquina de trazer
os leads para pois estou tendo
dificuldades com tráfego sim dentro do
nosso trabalho já tem a a máquina de
trazer os pacientes os lades
tá Isaías já vou dar um nome para minha
I será Marília maravilha aí a María amor
né É
claro Alex para uma clínica
multidisciplinar Tem de vários médicos
procedimentos Sim a gente tem clínica
multidisciplinar aqui dentro de
Antônio Gostei da maneira de
acompanhamento pós consulta está aí o
segredo da fidelização Com
certeza Karina senta de novo por favor
[Música]
Larissa perguntou podemos ir
reformulando aí a após a implementação
sim Larissa claro que a gente consegue
tá de acordo com demandas de acordo com
Ah quero adicionar novas informações
quero mudar o preço da minha consulta
Quero mostrar meus diferenciais quero
mudar o objetivo não tem problema tá
FT não sei o seu nome tenta agendar
novamente por
favor João Adorei a apresentação
Parabéns pela oratória e clareza da fala
muito
obrigada já agendei vamos para cima
vamos Jaqueline falou tem como me mandar
o link dessa reunião para que minha
administradora possa assistir participar
da reunião Jaqueline eu vou vou falar
com com me equipe enviar para você
tá tem CRM eu não entendi Vitor se o CRM
você tá falando do CRM da gestão dos
contatos Se for isso sim e se tá
perguntando se eu tenho CRM sim
também Diego falou temho interesse na ia
humanizado vocês fazem sim Diego pode
agendar sua reunião
tá Dra Michele tá perguntando tem jeito
mesmo sem eds Claro Michele sem o eds
você tem eh uma inteligência artificial
que faz todo o papel de uma secretária
então claro que vale a
pena pessoal
Doutora Como é seu nome
Estela Silmara Quem irá entrar em
contato comigo é Bruno Sim Bruno pode
entrar em contato a Fernanda pode entrar
em contato Ariane pode entrar em contato
também
tá quem tem agência de marketing poderá
dispensar
pode mas aí é com vocês né não posso
dizer que para vocês
dispensarem
Silmara você tá me falando que marcou a
reunião não tem problema ó
o a nossa equipe vai entrar em contato
caso você não possa ou queira antecipar
ou Queira mudar vão conversar com você
tá bom para ver sua disponibilidade e a
disponibilidade da equipe
também pessoal
já tá tarde né eu quero agradecer vocês
pela participação pela participação no
chat também foi muito bom prazer
conhecer vocês quem tá indo pra próxima
etapa com a gente paraa nossa reunião de
diagnóstico e análise sejam bem-vindos
tá vamos conversar e mostrar o que essa
inteligência artificial vai fazer no
negócio de vocês tá bom então muito
obrigada Jaqueline não sei se respondeu
minha pergunta eu respondi tanta
pergunta
mas Jaqueline você já tá agendada né
pelo que eu pelo que eu vi aqui então
fica tranquila nossa equipe vai entrar
em contato com vocês Tá participem da
reunião pessoal se não puderem avisa com
antecedência tá então Obrigada boa noite
boa semana a
todos n